Speaker 1: It's great to have back on the
program today Dean Baker, who's a senior economist
at the Center for Economic and Policy Research
and also a visiting professor at the University
of Utah.
Dean, we spoke about a year ago, most recently,
and we now have a very different situation
from the standpoint of the pandemic economically.
What are you most paying attention to and
what is of concern at this point?
Speaker 5: Well, the economy is recovering
rapidly and that that's a very good story.
I mean, we still have a lot of people out
of work.
We're still not back to what we might consider
normal, certainly far from full employment.
But to my view, the question is the rate at
which we're going and the extent to which
we see obstacles.
One of the big things or the big thing, of
course, is the pandemic itself.
I mean, we have the numbers way, way down
because primarily because of the vaccines,
which have been great.
But we know there's a lot of people who don't
want to take them.
And as a result of that, they're getting sick
there.
So that's a bad story.
Now, as it stands, I don't think there's a
big economic problem with that.
I mean, I don't want to trivialize people
getting sick and dying.
That's a big deal.
But I mean, if we're just talking about the
economic impact, I think that's relatively
limited.
The big concern and this should be a huge
warning to us.
We, of course, are talking about the Delta
variant and the vaccines are still affected
from that.
But as long as the pandemic is spreading out
of control, not here.
I mean, obviously, we care about here, too,
but around the world, we're not going to be
safe.
And that's a really, really big deal.
So I wished we had done I wish we still now
do more to get the world vaccinated.
So that's a really, really big story.
But the other part, just how do things look
in the economy right now?
Well, we've had fantastic job growth the last
four month, over six hundred thousand a month.
We're going to we'll get GDP report next week.
And the second quarter's almost certainly
going to put us above where we were pre pandemic.
I mean, we have a ways to go yet to be back
on trend, but most things are looking pretty
good.
And so, you know, as the economy goes, I'm
feeling pretty good about it.
You know, we just have to make sure we could
slow the growth of the pandemic, partly here,
but probably more importantly, right now around
the world,
Speaker 1: there's been this refrain or talking
point.
Call it what you will in the context of this
enhanced unemployment benefit that the federal
government established during the pandemic.
That now is things are opening.
There's a worker shortage.
Businesses are having trouble finding people
to work because people, quote, would rather
sit at home and collect their enhanced unemployment.
Now, we have some early data from some states
that decided to get ahead of Joe Biden September
date and just cut the enhanced unemployment
early.
It's not totally clear that it's really having
a definitive impact, actually, on the rate
at which people are starting to look for jobs
or being hired.
Generally speaking, my view is most people
want to work and most people find, for better
or worse, they find meaning and identity through
work.
And that could be a bad thing or a good thing.
We could talk about that, but that the kind
of free rider, the people who just would prefer
to sit at home and not work are so, so small
in number that they're not significant.
What's your sense of that talking point?
Speaker 5: Yeah, well, you know, everyone's
got their lazy cousin who's sitting at home
collecting benefits and they extrapolate to
the whole world and that's how many lives
out there actually exist.
But in any case, you know, everyone could
say they know someone and some people surely
are.
But there's been a lot of research on this.
And I remember we had six hundred dollars
a week suppliments back in the original curve's
act.
Right.
And the number of efforts to study the impact
of that.
And they found it was very little, wasn't
zero.
I mean, obviously there's some people that
will make a difference for but there was relatively
little impact.
And you mentioned that now you have several
states that have jumped the gun or whatever
term you want to use.
They've suspended ended the benefits early.
And my friend Aaron Bass at the University
of Massachusetts analyzed what the performance
has been in the states that have been to benefits
early compared to other states.
And there's no difference.
In fact, I think there's a very small uptick.
I mean, I'm not going to blame it on that.
But I think they actually had somewhat higher
unemployment and a rise in unemployment relative
to other states.
So the idea that that's a major factor in
keeping people from looking for work, I just
don't buy it.
What I do think is going on is you have a
lot of businesses really opening at the same
time.
And the biggest story, of course, is restaurants.
That's the one that was hardest hit.
And now they're reopening.
So they're looking all hire a lot of workers
at the same time.
And it shouldn't be surprising that that's
it's not that easy that that, you know, they're
in a situation.
They can't get the workers they need.
They're bidding up wages.
I mean, that's a good thing in my view.
But in any case, that's really not a terribly
surprising story, nor necessarily a bad story.
And in any case, it doesn't seem as though
the unemployment supplements are a big part
of the picture.
Speaker 1: Is it as simple as some others
are saying, which is.
Well.
It's just now the businesses that the employers
need to compete for, the apparently temporarily
limited pool of potential workers, and this
should just mean that they pay more and then
it'll solve everybody's problem.
Is it that simple?
Speaker 5: It is.
I think that's basically a story in some business
to say that, well, I can't afford to pay higher
wages.
And I'm sure in some cases that's true.
And, you know, look, this is a capitalist
economy.
And, you know, some businesses, businesses
go out of business all the time.
I mean, it sure was that I mean, I know people
put their pulao work and many cases their
life savings, you know, so so I don't mean
to trivialize that, but that is the reality.
So in some cases, we'll have situations where
businesses just aren't going to be profitable.
And I understand they don't want to say, well,
if I get away with paying workers 10 an hour,
15 things, but sorry, you know, that's that's
going to be the world.
And so so I just don't see this as the big
crisis that's being portrayed as
Speaker 1: on the other side of this is pricing
and inflation.
During the pandemic, we saw really significant
increases in some products.
Lumber was a big one that had some sort of
follow on effects in terms of building of
new construction, homes, renovations, et cetera.
The price of lumber has now actually dropped
precipitously, although that drop does not
yet seem to have filtered through as much
as it maybe will to the end.
Products that the lumber is is used for some
of the inflation data that we see compared,
for example, May twenty one to May 20.
So you're sort of comparing to when there
was a significant demand collapse and maybe
that's not the right way to look at it.
What's your perspective on this issue of inflation?
Speaker 5: Well, I think for the most part,
it's reasonably well under control, so again,
the way to make comparison are now our June
to June.
But I mean, that's you know, it's kind of
silly because it's you know, these are months
where prices were badly depressed.
So if you look at what inflation's done since
February, the last prepend month, it's up.
So there's no doubt about it.
But an overwhelmingly large share of that
is simply cars, both new and used cars.
And we know what the story is there.
There was a fire in a semiconductor factory
in Japan, and that's led to a worldwide shortage
of semiconductors, which has limited the production
of new cars.
And what that's mean is people have money
now from the various pandemic programs.
They want to buy a car, new cars that they
can't get a new car.
So they buy a used car and use car prices
have just gone through the roof.
They've actually begun to fall by some measures
as of June.
So we'll see how that pans out over the rest
of the year.
But that's the bulk of the uptick in inflation.
So it's hard to get too concerned about that.
My expectation is that we're going to see
those prices falling through the rest of the
year.
I mean, they'll still be higher than a two
20 level, but they're going to be falling
from where they were in June.
So I'm not that concerned about that.
Other areas of The New York Times that a big
piece on housing house prices, sale prices
have risen a lot.
And that's because a lot of people are moving
that we have very low mortgage interest rates
and you have a lot of people that are moving
from expensive places like New York, Washington,
where I came from, and they're moving to cheaper
places around the country and pushing putting
a big upward pressure on prices there.
New York and some of the more expensive ones.
It's price growth is slowing.
In some cases they're actually going negative.
But, you know, but that's that's a big story.
Now, whether that leads to sustained increase
in rents, I think it's a little too early
to tell.
I was struck and I know this isn't necessarily
a good story, but if we're trying to sell
the picture of the housing market, we have
to consider we're ending the the eviction
moratorium ends at the end of this month.
And there are reports, I think these are exaggerated,
that somewhere around seven or eight million
people face eviction.
I don't think anything like that will actually
be evicted, but a lot of people will be.
You know, again, I don't I'm not saying it's
a good thing.
I'm just saying if we're looking at the housing
market and let's say we have 800000 people
evict, I'm pulling that someone out better.
But it will be a lot that's a lot of vacant
units.
So, you know, it's again, I don't mean to
say any of this is good.
That isn't.
But we have a lot of turmoil in the economy
right now, which has led to inflation in some
areas, you know, as mentioned in cars that
could identify some others.
But it's not an underlying it's not the sort
of inflation we saw in the 70s where you had
higher wages, driving higher prices, leading
workers to push for higher wages.
And then we got the spiraling upward.
We're very, very far from that story.
Speaker 1: You mentioned in the car discussion
that now part of this is people have money
to spend and they want cars as they get back
to things.
One of the interesting things that we saw,
so to kind of set this up pre pandemic, frequently,
we would see articles with headlines like
40 percent of Americans would need to borrow
to meet an unexpected 400 dollar expense.
And about the the point of those stories was
very low savings rate in the United States
during the pandemic.
We saw headlines about dramatically higher
savings rate in the United States at a macroeconomic
level.
How should we think about that?
Because there's a school of thought that keeping
money in bank accounts instead of spending
it has a very low economic multiplier and
is not so good for the economy.
Although at the individual level, certainly
we can understand how having an emergency
fund is a very good thing for a household
budget.
So how should we be thinking about that?
Speaker 5: Well, there's two issues here.
One is if we're thinking of just immediate
demand in the economy, that does restrain
demand.
So if I have got my twelve hundred or fourteen
hundred dollar check from President Biden
and go, OK, well, I'm put putting the banks,
I need to spend it right now.
Well, if we're worried about inflation, that's
actually a good thing.
So so if we're worried, there's going to be
too much demand in the economy, that's a good
thing.
So I think he has that has worked out.
It's basically been a positive for the economy
in the sense that is we're having this reopening
and there's a lot of stress in different areas.
It probably is a good thing that everyone
does and rush out and spending it now, say,
six months a year down the road.
As you say, the flip side, the micro side
is, OK, I've got money in the bank.
I feel better.
And we know I mean, there's a lot of data.
People's balance sheets are better than they've
been in decades.
Right.
So things really look much better.
So that's great both in their security, but
also maybe they want to do a big ticket purchase.
Maybe they're going to use that money as a
down payment on a house or a car or whatever
it might be.
So I can say they're overwhelmingly positive
that, again, if we were worried, oh, we need
more demand in the economy right now, then
people saving is definitely a bad thing.
But we're not in that situation, or at least
I don't.
I believe we're in that situation, so I'm
very happy to see that a lot of people are
in a situation where they could save some
of their money and again, they could always
keep it there as a reserve or they may decide
six months, a year down the road to have a
big ticket purchase to other.
Speaker 1: I don't know if we would call them
trends or things that have kind of been topics
of conversation as a result of the pandemic.
One is work from home and the different decisions
that are being taken by decisions being made
by corporations about we will do permanent,
possible work from home or we will do a split
of work from home and be back in the office,
etc..
That's one trend.
The other one is we're also getting more and
more information from these four day a week
work trials, which sometimes are a full 40
hours, but over four days, and sometimes they're
actually fewer hours, like a 36 or thirty
seven hour week over four days.
And looking at what employee productivity
is over that period of time rather than forty
or forty five hours.
What's your thought on these things at sort
of this point in time, but also bigger picture.
Speaker 5: I think they're both very encouraging
trends, taking one at a time.
Yeah, the work home, clearly we're going to
see way, way more work from home than than
we did pre pandemic.
I mean, the point is, you know, business inertia
is an incredibly powerful force in the economy.
People have to appreciate that for a long
time.
As an economist ago, maybe it should be like
this rather than that and go, well, maybe
it should be, but it's not going to be.
Well, right.
Once employers got used to having people working
from home and they kept their business operating,
then they can't say it doesn't work.
They know it works.
So we are going to see many more situations
where either people are totally working from
home or cases where maybe they come in once
or twice a week from the office.
And I think that's a great thing from a number
of different perspectives.
Obviously, it saves enormous amount of resources,
commuting people's time.
I mean, obviously, people value their time.
And if you're commuting two hours a day, one
hour each way that you're wasting your time
on anyone.
I mean, there's a lot of things we could argue.
How much do you like this or that?
And when you watch their commute and, you
know, I'm sure someone somewhere does.
Speaker 1: But that's I think I think just
to interject one idea there.
There are some studies about if you have a
15 minute commute that it seems sort of for
a lot of people to be a positive kind of change
of phase from home to work.
And that that, you know, once you get longer
than that, the duration of it seems to start
having like a more of a net negative effect.
Speaker 5: Yeah, I believe that I mean, a
short enough commute I can grant isn't a big
deal, you know, just to walk to work.
I was lucky enough for for a period of time
to be able to walk to work.
It was maybe half mile, so.
Yeah.
And, you know, ten minutes or so.
So, yeah, that was fine.
That that didn't bother me at first.
I think the vast majority of commuters are
considerably more time, so.
Yeah.
So I think that's a great thing and I think
it's it's good, of course, from environmental
perspective, you know, where people don't.
Obviously a lot of resources are wasted in
commuting.
So so that's a great story.
Four day work week, I think.
Similar story.
Again, if you compare the US to Europe, there
have been sharp reductions in work hours over
the last four decades.
And I was going to say most all European countries
and we now are average work year in the United
States, twenty, twenty five percent longer
than it is in Germany and Netherlands, Denmark,
other wealthy countries.
And I think most people do value their time.
And if we could have a four day workweek rather
than a five, that's great.
And yeah, I'd love to see the hours cut because
I think a 10 hour day, certainly in a lot
of jobs, people would find exhausting.
So if we can make it a nine hour day, maybe
somewhere down the road, maybe an eight hour
day, but whatever, nine hours isn't that much
worse than eight.
So, you know, I think most people would consider
that a pretty good deal.
And again, getting back to the commuting,
if you have for commute rather than five,
that's that's a plus.
So I'd love to see us get to to shorter work
years.
And a four day workweek is really good.
Way to go,
Speaker 1: without a doubt.
I'm with you there, Dean.
We've been speaking with Dean Baker, who's
a senior economist at the Center for Economic
and Policy Research, also a visiting professor
at the University of Utah.
Always great having you on.
Speaker 5: Well, thanks for having me on.
Good questions.